although they're often electric
on-screen kisses aren't always planned
from the tender to the funny to the
deeply controversial here are a few
on-screen kisses that we're never
supposed to happen one of Lost in
translation's most iconic scenes
revolves around the tender moment shared
at the end of the movie between Scarlett
Johansson's Charlotte and Bill Murray's
character Bob during filming Murray
famously whispered something in
Johansson's ear that neither actor has
revealed the ensuing kiss wasn't planned
either
when asked about the scene director
Sophia Coppola told The Daily Beast I
remember sometimes Murray would spring
things on Johansson and it was fun to
get her reaction
during stranger things 2's season finale
Lucas and newcomer Max share a kiss at
their school's Winter Dance in an
episode of the after show series Beyond
stranger things Sadie sink who played
Max explained that the kiss was a
surprise and that showrunners Matt and
Ross Duffer sprang it on her the day of
filming oh Sadie you ready for the kiss
look what nope no that's not in the
script okay that's not happening Ross
Duffer had previously joked with sync
about her kissing her co-star Caleb
McLaughlin and the idea had stressed her
out so much that he decided to have it
happen for real it was a decision which
sparked outrage online in Wake of the
controversy sync told the rap that she
had always felt comfortable on set
saying The Duffer Brothers always create
a comfortable space and if I felt
uncomfortable with anything I wouldn't
have done it anyways it's great I can't
imagine without a thinking Yeah well
yeah you're welcome
Luke and Leia scene towards the end of
The Last Jedi is arguably one of the
movie's finest moments it's an exchange
which carries extra weight considering
Carrie Fisher's tragic passing only
months after filming ended the scene is
punctuated by her forehead kiss from
Luke to Leia which was improvised on
Mark Hamill's part it was just
spontaneous and a really momentous for
me because Luke was saying goodbye to
his sister forever Hamel has been unable
to watch the scene since she'll be
forever missed and she's Irreplaceable
after the home release of The Hunger
Games Mockingjay Part 2 Woody Harrelson
told Entertainment Tonight that his
on-screen kiss with Elizabeth Banks had
nothing to do with the script she didn't
know I was even gonna do it and I just
kissed her Harrelson later told the
Associated Press I I personally always
wanted to kiss her I don't know if it
was the right thing to do and although
Harrelson denied knowing it the ap's
reporter claimed she'd heard that Banks
intentionally flubbed takes during the
scene so she could keep locking lips
with Harrelson thanks to the logistical
realities of filming a television show
an unplanned kiss between two actors can
often involve more people than initially
intended that's what happened after Game
of Thrones actors Gemma Wieland and
Indira Varma improvised a kiss between
their characters Yara Greyjoy and
ellaria sand
oh
seems like you don't need a protector
this moment takes place on a ship just
prior to an attack by antagonist euron
Greyjoy Whelan's back was injured at the
time however and since she couldn't
perform all of her stunts her double was
brought in to replace her and also had
to kiss Varma Varma told Entertainment
Weekly that I had to start kissing the
sports stunt double and she was so
terrified I don't think she'd ever been
put in that situation before she's used
to falling over and being attacked and
all the stunts but to be kissed by an
actress was a bit beyond her
according to Bryce Dallas Howard the
kiss between her character Claire and
Chris Pratt's Owen was never in the
script for Jurassic world she told Out
magazine we had shot the scene in the
way that it was written there was no
kiss and then on the last day that
happened what you see in the movie the
movie's director Colin travaro however
has since revealed that it wasn't
entirely spontaneous he took Pratt aside
and suggested he kissed Howard but never
told her on Jurassic world's commentary
he explained the idea was we're just
going to have Chris Pratt's surprise
Howard in front of 200 people and that's
the take that's in the movie
during the season 3 premiere of The
Office Steve Carell's character Michael
Learns that his employee Oscar played by
Oscar Nunez is gay in a misguided
attempt to prove how tolerant he is this
happens
according to Nunez however the script
only called for Corel to hug him he told
the AV club we were just supposed to hug
and he kept hugging me and that
particular take he came in really close
and I'm like where is he going with this
see
David O Russell didn't cast Jennifer
Lawrence in his 2013 black comedy
American Hustle until very late into the
casting process the director told Vanity
Fair that even though she was young for
the role Lawrence had a quote Timeless
quality and that she took to the park
chemically since we're talking about an
improvised kiss scene between Lawrence
and Amy Adams it would be interesting to
learn exactly which chemicals Russell
was talking about Lawrence played
Rosalind Rosenfeld wife to con man
Irving Rosenfeld played by Christian
Bale at a pivotal moment in the film
Rosalind argues with Irving's mistress
Sydney played by Amy Adams in a bathroom
and in the middle of the confrontation
Rosalind aggressively kisses Sydney and
then bursts into cruel laughter Russell
said the kiss was improvised recalling
that the idea was pitched to him but
that it didn't exactly fit his vision in
a 2013 press conference about the movie
Adam said even though the kiss was her
idea the credit for the moment goes to
Lawrence Adams went on to say the kiss
didn't just feel like a moment where two
girls are going to kiss on screen it
felt emotional and called Lawrence's
laugh that followed the kiss genius
in 2014's Edge of Tomorrow United
Defense Force Major William Cage played
by Tom Cruise is arrested by a superior
officer for insubordination during an
alien invasion after his records are
deliberately altered to make it look
like he's a private cage is forced into
action where he quickly dies in battle
only to discover he's trapped in a Time
Loop where he relives the same day
leading up to his death over and over
his only Ally is Rita vatasky played by
Emily Blunt a highly regarded Sergeant
who's also the only person who accepts
that his time looping dilemma is real
wake up
speaking to film School rejects
screenwriter Christopher McCrory said
the filmmakers struggled to find a place
in the film for cage and Rita to kiss
but nothing they tried seemed genuine he
said it always felt false it always felt
like they weren't focused on what was
really important macquarrie and his
colleagues gave up on the kiss
completely but apparently blunt hadn't
Macquarie said that as they shot a scene
in which Rita says goodbye to cage blunt
just kissed him goodbye in the moment
and it was not in the script it was not
even discussed according to Macquarie
after the scene was filmed blunt said it
just felt right it felt right and I did
it in season four of Riverdale CW's teen
drama paid tribute to hedvik and the
Angry Inch a stage musical later adapted
to film about an East German trans rock
singer in the 80s in the episode chapter
74 Wicked little town Casey kotts Kevin
Keller decides it's time for Riverdale
High to host variety shows again when
principal honey warns Kevin not to
perform any numbers from hedvig Kevin
and his friends fight back by performing
multiple numbers from the musical during
the hedvig original tear me down Kevin
and KJ appa's Archie lock lips and
according to cut even though the kiss
was never planned it absolutely had to
happen Cod explained to TV Insider that
there is a part of the hedvik stage
musical when the titular hero goes into
the audience and kisses an audience
member inspired by this while filming
his performance of tear me down with
cots Kevin Keller playing Hedwig Kant
kissed APA on the cheek but then as Cod
explained the next take I went in to do
the same thing and APPA turned his face
and we just kind of laid a big one on
each other and then after that we were
like this is exactly what it should be
this is like perfect for this number
thankfully everyone agreed and the kiss
made the Final Cut
from the beginning of the Sci-Fi crime
drama Person of Interest fans noticed
romantic tension between Jim caviezel's
CIA operative John Reese an NYPD
detective Joss Carter played by Taraji P
Henson however it takes until the third
season for those feelings to find any
kind of physical expression in season
threes The Crossing Reese and Carter
finally share a kiss while they're
hiding from the bad guys in a morgue
sadly it's destined to be their first
and last at the end of the episode The
corrupt cup Patrick Simmons ambushes
them and shoots them both before running
away they're both hit but Carter is
mortally wounded and she dies in Reese's
arms according to the show's producers
even though the kiss was a landmark
moment for the characters it was a
decision the actors made completely on
their own Person of Interest executive
producer Greg plagueman told The
Hollywood Reporter the kiss was not
scripted we never wrote it in it wasn't
in every take there were takes where
they didn't do it and there were takes
where they did plagueman went on to say
that when they looked at the takes
without the kiss it felt like something
was missing and that the kiss deepened
the connection between the characters
sometimes an unplanned kiss in a TV show
or a movie will generate controversy
felt well outside the editing room and
that's something Tommy Davidson learned
while filming the 1998 romantic comedy
woo Jada Pinkett Smith played Davidson's
love interest in the rom-com and in his
2020 Memoir living in color what's funny
about me Davidson writes that neither he
nor Smith were satisfied with the
script's ending he says he pitched the
idea of ending Wu with the couple
dancing in the middle of a city street
and apparently everyone liked the idea
while dancing with his co-star in the
new scene Davidson kissed Smith without
warning though he said Smith flinched
when he kissed her at the time he quote
didn't think it was all that big of a
deal but there was someone who thought
it was a big deal Jada Pinkett Smith's
husband Will Smith according to Davidson
after the scene was shot Will Smith
followed Davidson into his trailer and
things got very heated between the two
Davidson explained there was a moment
there when we might have come to blows
my reactive fighter flight Instinct was
triggered and I could have exploded
thankfully Jada stepped in and helped
calm things down and Davidson and will
remained good friends afterwards I was
just about to retaliate
between the 60s and 80s Valerie Leon
made a name for herself playing young
Beauties particularly in James bondflex
she appeared in both 1977's the spy who
loved me 1983's Never Say Never Again in
a 2017 interview with West and dextra
Leon named one of the Bond actors Roger
Moore as one of her favorite actors to
work with along with the spy who loved
me she worked with more in the TV series
the Saints and the 1978 War film The
Wild Geese but Leon said that one of her
favorite collaborations with Moore was
on the early 70s action comedy TV series
The persuaders she appears as space
queen in the long goodbye as one of a
number of women claiming to be heiress
to a dead scientist she recalled Roger
gave me an unscripted kiss I just closed
my eyes and enjoyed it they kept it in
there have been plenty of steamy moments
on the medical drama Gray's Anatomy but
in the show's season 14 finale there is
one that was less steamy but Glennie
surprising for almost everyone involved
early in the episode all of me even
though she's about to get married to
Justin Chambers Alex and everyone
insists they can't see one another
before the wedding Camilla ludington's
Joe rushes to see Alex and her other
friends because she has news she can't
keep to herself she's just learned she's
been tapped for a highly sought after
surgery fellowship at Massachusetts
General Hospital ignoring all the
protests about not seeing her fiance Joe
announces it to her friends predictably
kisses Alex and then much less
predictably kisses Jessica capshaw's
Arizona before giving her fiance a
second kiss it's just a quick kiss but
Capshaw is visibly surprised and the
moment didn't go unnoticed by the
audience asked about the kiss on Twitter
Ludington responded ha it was unscripted
but I thought hello who wouldn't want to
also smooch Arizona Robbins fitting you
could interpret it as a kiss goodbye as
all of me was capshaw's Final appearance
on the series
the model L McPherson hasn't done a lot
of acting work and when she started
1997's the edge she'd done even less
McPherson plays Mickey wife of
billionaire Charles Morse played by
Anthony Hopkins Hopkins and his co-star
Alec Baldwin who plays photographer Bob
Green have the Lion's Share of screen
time early in the film Morse suspects
Bob is having an affair with Mickey and
this is confirmed at a particularly
inconvenient time when Morris and green
are trapped in the wilderness and
fighting for their lives against a
massive Kodiak bear in a 2011 episode of
The Graham Norton Show McPherson said
her unexpected kiss with Hopkins took
place during the auditioning process for
the edge rather than during the filming
and it wasn't so much that the kiss was
unexpected but the type of Kiss was a
shock she said during the audition the
casting directors emphasized that in
spite of the 27-year age difference
between her and Hopkins it was important
that they feel quote connected and
intimate with each other so it was
suggested they kiss McPherson explained
to Norton that having not done much
acting work she wasn't sure if she
should quote kiss with the tongue
without the tongue and she aired on the
side of well the side of tongue he went
so red
oh it's blasted I got the job though
foreign
[Music]